hello everyone and welcome to the final
day of the preliminaries of the charity
cup it is a game a lot of you have
already requested while it was being
played magnus carlsen versus juventun uh
so the world uh chess champion were also
versus the women's world chess champion
uh she won the title three times and she
will defend her title again this year so
without further ado let's check it out
and see what's happening it's a very
very uh very close game uh so magnus
with the dwight pieces opens with e4 we
have e5 knight to f3 knight to c6 and
bishop to b5 uh the rue lopez is on the
board we have a6 morpheus defense bishop
to a4 and knight to f6 we have castles
and bishop to c5 going for the new
archangels
structure we have c3 and now b5 chasing
away across his bishop here bishop to b3
and d6 so this is all very very standard
stuff nothing new here both of them
playing very a very strong theory we
have a4 challenging this expansion on
the queen side and now bishop to b7 as
well if pawn capture spawn captures the
rook will hang on a8 so we have to play
bishop to b7 defender rook and it's also
a nice diagonal for our bishop and here
usually d4 is the main idea but magnus
plays the uh the lesser move or you know
uh it's not a lesser move but
it's not played as much so d3 are still
waiting with the exchanges and here
just castles we have bishop the g5 by
magnus h6 bishop to h4 and now there are
a couple of games that reach this exact
same position interestingly magnus
carlsen already had this position in
2013 in the tata steel tournament
against ivan sokolov where the game
continued with queen to e7 uh also some
known ideas are g5 just pushing the
bishop back to g3 but here we have rook
to b8 by joo
and it is now already as of movie 11
that we have a completely new game uh
this basically means that uh the a file
is uh white's the control and if uh the
position clears up a little bit you
might be able to use it so here magnus
opens up the a file captures captures
and knight b to d2
we have bishop back to c8 now the rook
would be
well or rather could be useful on the b
file if the position opens up and we
might be interested in pinning this
knight with bishop to g4 so magnus stops
this plays h3 and bishop to e6 now but
bishop to e6 might be a slight
imprecision and magnus quickly shows why
he plays bishop to d5 attacks the knight
here and now
as you can see the knight doesn't really
have any squares this is covered this is
covered this is covered that this is
covered by the rook but uh
also if you put the knight there then a
move like d4 might um
be very unpleasant if you play the
knight to e7 then we can capture on f6
and mess up the pawn structure as the
queen no longer guards the knight so
here you don't really have a good move
right maybe capturing the bishop but
this just loses on the spot because
after he captures the knight again
doesn't really have
a a good square even if knight to a7 now
we can simply play bishop captures on f6
and after queen captures and now we go
knight to e4 we attack the queen and the
bishop once the queen moves we eliminate
the bishop and then we pick up the
knight on a7 uh so similar to the to the
line that we've discussed so here bishop
back to b7 sort of uh wasting a move a
little bit and now uh what do you play
here uh well a strongest idea here seems
to be just the trading bishop captures
bishop captures and now d4 grabbing more
space in the center and after captures
and captures bishop to b4 and now queen
to b3 this is what the engine thinks
that um
that will give white a great position as
the c file is now very weak we can bring
the rook to the c file also the bishop
here is very weak so you might have to
give up the bishop fair uh but magnus
says nonsense uh the strongest move is
always and almost in any position pawn
to b4 so this is what he plays he
attacks the bishop here bishop back to
b6 and now bishop back to b3 so he wants
to keep his bishop here not traded for
the knight on c6 and now you just plays
a g5 chases away the bishop bishop to g3
and now again you have to play it very
very precisely you have to decide
whether to maybe play bishop to e6 now
as this was your original plan or go for
rook to e8 but she goes knight to h5 and
this just completely opens up the board
uh so of course her plan is to capture
the bishop as you will not be able to
recapture the bishop here is preventing
this uh
pawn from moving as i know a lot of you
guys forgot about this bishop so here uh
magnus just goes knight captures on e5
now okay the queen is threatening to
pick up the knight on h5 so she has to
play knight captures on g3 and now the
question is how do you play this of
course we play knight captures on d7
queen captures on d7 and rook to e1 so
what's happening here if you count the
pieces here it seems that magnus is down
a piece but
even though this knight on g3 is still
alive how do you
how do you
keep it and this is a very important
moment in the game and even though uh
jew has a lot of time here the situation
on the clock is 12 minutes for magnus
and eight minutes for you uh she spends
seven minutes on her next move as it's a
very very important one how do you
continue you could continue incredibly
aggressive uh with g4 then magnus of
course would play d4 he would block this
diagonal and then you would
just pick up the knight but black would
get the attack on the other hand you
could play d5 this central breakthrough
this is according to the engine the
absolute best move so she calculated it
precisely uh the problem is she is now
uh below the one minute mark whereas
magnus has still has eight minutes on
the clock so magnus plays e captures on
d5 and now knight to e7 now going for
the full attack with knight to f5 knight
to h4 he just wants to go all in uh and
if magnus tries to play something like
c4 and c5 then we can play bishop d4 and
you are not locking out this bishop from
this diagonal
attack the rook let's say after rook to
c1 we can go now night the knight eat
the f5 knight stage four and continue
our attack and this would be uh
incredibly difficult to stop for white
as the black is still up a piece so uh
that's very important so instead after
knight to e7 we have queen uh knight's
d7 was played uh instead of this uh and
now comes uh a queen to g4
so again what do you play here uh you
could trade queens but uh you you you
probably don't want to you probably want
to just defend this knight and queen to
d6 here seems to be like maybe uh the
the safest thing to do uh
but the problem is there's always this
rook captures an e7 idea and we will be
picking up that night so probably rook
captures queen captures and queen
captures on g3 now we give give back a
little material and the end result would
be this that jew would be up
at the exchange she would have a rook
for a knight on the downside magnus
would be up to pawn so it would it would
be a pretty equalish position however
after queen to g4 she played knight g to
f5 and now things uh start to get very
very interesting now magnus will again
give up the rook rook captures an e7
queen captures and queen captures an f5
but now uh white's pieces are
much much much better placed so king to
g7 again you do not want your king on
this diagonal you know that this pawn is
marching forward at some point and then
queen to g6 check idea will be possible
as the f1 will be
unable to recapture here so king to g7
very important move to include now
knight to e4 and now you can already
imagine this knight coming to will uh
maybe maybe the g3 maybe the h5 then to
f6 could be very very dangerous we have
rook b to e8 uh and now magnus should
continue with this plan knight g3 maybe
here to here but he goes for d6 he wants
to open up this bishop's diagonal and
now uh what can she play well she plays
a queen to e5 pretty instantly because
she's pretty much out of time
and she offers a queen trade and while
this is very good for white magnus plays
g4 instead he wants to complete the
trade on his terms c captures on d6 and
now rook to a6 harassing the bishop here
we have bishop to c7 and now magnus goes
for rook to a7 again knights to g3 is
always an idea as especially now if
queens get traded off you can capture
this with check and now
it's just uh well
very very hard for black to play this
the bishop isn't all that great the
rook's not controlling all that much
white is still up
up up upon and even though black is up
the exchange it will be very very
difficult to play this so instead after
bishop c7 rook to a7 by magnus again
attacking the bishop here and now she
counters with d5 challenges the knight
here and now uh magnus captures bishop
captures on the e5 and the queen
captures an f5 we have g captures on f5
and now as the bishop is still hanging
we have bishop to f4 probably uh the
last attempt at the defense was rook to
d8 challenging the light square bishop
which is uh undefended on d5 but even
this would be difficult to hold so
bishop to f4 was played but now magnus
just goes in for the kill knight to c5
now threatening knight to the e6 check
which would win significant material as
the f pawn is again unable to capture
rook to e1 with check with king to g2
now king to g8
not uh
pinning basically but not knight to d7
attacking the roku going after this
beautiful f6 square she plays rook to e7
but now it's a very clean win for magnus
feel free to pause the video here and
try to find the absolute strongest move
for white while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting uh any of
the of the winning ideas like f6 but the
absolute strongest and quickest way to
win is the move that magnus plays and
that is knight to f6 check this means
that now we are winning the rook uh or
if king to g7 then uh she will be hoping
for rook captures rook and king captures
knight but after king to g7 magnus just
played knight to h5 we've reached the
position from the thumbnail and he was
in this position on move 37 that joe and
jun resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here so the g6
square is covered f6 squares uh is also
covered the king cannot access those
squares so you cannot attack the knight
you cannot defend the rook and once the
king moves we're just going to pick up
the rook and now we are up
a full piece also we are just uh i mean
we are completely winning even without
that piece uh so this would be uh too
overwhelming uh so yeah after uh this uh
uh
knight to h5 check uh jew resigned the
game and a wonderful wonderful victory
for magnus carlsen in this penultimate
round of the of the charity cup
preliminaries uh so yeah as you can see
uh she uh defended very well or rather
she played the entire game very well and
it all came down to this moment
basically where she spent most of her
time
well she had eight minutes on the clock
the decide whether to go for this very
aggressive g4 or d5 idea both of them uh
having their merits but she decided to
go for d5 like i said the absolute
strongest uh evaluated by the engine uh
and while it is uh
the absolute strongest uh she invested
too much time in it and it was uh simply
impossible to play out the rest of the
game with less than a minute on the
clock sure you get increment but it's
you know 15 seconds where every move is
is a critical one so yeah you're not
going to be able to pile up time you
know play a couple of quick moves in
succession to maybe you know get like
that
two minutes on the clock so that's
that's definitely not happening
uh but yeah i once again hope you guys
uh enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
board blueberry friends nft uh yonatan
uh
sarnieto uh stefan harris berger uh
michael calbera and jay langdon
consulting for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the
charity cup preliminaries until it
finishes so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day